um hi everyone
uh thank you for coming to the talk
today i'm going to be talking about
symbolic determinant identity testing
and non-communicative ranks of matrix dr
difference there's a joint work with my
amazing collaborators rabo ribanyos and
you mean char
so the outline for today's talk is as
follows
we'll first introduce the problem and
look at reasons uh why this might be
interesting to people
we'll then uh do a quick survey uh on
the history of the problem
and then state our results uh
very uh briefly
in the next part of the talk which is
slightly more technical we'll state the
definitions and which will allow us to
state our results in its complete form
and moreover we'll give some proof
sketch
and finally i'll conclude with the
summary and some open problems
so let's begin
so
a lot of you might be familiar with the
polynomial identity testing problem
uh so here you have an access to a
function f which is a polynomial
and
this kind of access is either black fox
or white phone and the blackbox setting
you can only query uh the function
whereas in the whitebox setting you can
also look at a circuit representation of
the polynomial which is a very succinct
encoding
of the problem
so the typical uh
axis as follows you evaluate it at point
so given a point v one up through t m
you can ask for the evaluation of this
polynomial and you get f of
z one times e
right
and the question is
is this polynomial identically zero or
not
right
and there's a natural randomized
algorithm you just query this at a lot
of points
uh if you ever find a point at which
this is nonzero
then definitely you know that it is
nonzero
else you can be fairly certain that it
is indeed the zero polynomial
and the challenge here is to
de-randomize this right to construct a
deterministically a set of such
evaluation points
a weakening of the problem would be to
ask even if they are asked if this if
this problem is even in np right
so can is there even
a succinct certificate that can certify
singularity
or certify that this polynomial is zero
right note that it is clearly in
quantity because if it is not a zero
then you have a point at which it
evaluates to one z
okay
so what is symbolic determinant identity
testing well it's a sub case of this
problem when the polynomial has a very
specific form which is it is the
determinant of a matrix whose each entry
is a linear form
right
so after separating out the variables i
can write it as summation x i a i where
you have x i ranges from 1 to m
and a i is a matrix scalar that is
element from the base field f
so again given uh a triple z1 through vm
you can evaluate this polynomial
and this case although it might seem
like a very special case of a general
polynomial it's quite general
right it's still very general
uh
there are multiple ways to see this but
uh
one reason
is this landmark results of cognition in
particular it says that
uh putting this problem in n sub x that
is
uh
showing that there are sub exponential
size certificates
already implies circuit lower bounds and
very good circle lower bounds that
which are far off from our current reach
so this this says that this is a very
interesting problem from the lower
bounds perspective
and the upshot
of this case
is that you can use linear algebra
right because this is a very linear
algebraic setup you have a bunch of
matrices you're computing the dominant
so you can hope to use linear algebra
all right
so let's view to the linear algebraic
viewpoint or the matrix space viewpoint
so we collect
these matrixes a 1 up to n in the
definition
and take the linear span and call it
this calligraphic a
right
it is a subspace
of the space of all matrices over f
which is a space of dimension and square
and this is a certain linear subspace of
that right denoted by a
and we say that a is singular if every
matrix is single
right so every matrix in this singular
uh we call this space the entire space a
to be singular and uh this is
it is easy to see that it is the same as
the symbolic determinant being zero
because you can interpret this matrix
summation x i ai
for each x for each uh
triple x you can interpret this as an
element of your linear space right
because it's a linear combination at the
end of the day
so this is a matrix in the matrix space
a
and this just says that every matrix in
the matrix space has a determinant 0
which is same as it being simpler
all right
so now there are two special kinds of
certificates
which have been studied
in the past
and for which we know
certain
algorithms
so the first kind
is what is known as a struct subspace
so let's first define a subspace
u and the action
of a on the substrate so matrices acts
on a subspace naturally by this
multiplication
and we just denote by shorthand a times
u to be the union of images for every a
in the matrix space a and a vector u in
the subspace
right so you collect this entire bunch
of vectors
exclamation in space
and the space u is called the sun
substrate
if after the action by a the dimension
is shrink
right
and in this case the space is also
called a non-commutation
okay
it might not really be clear why
the term non-communicativity is used
here but
we will not get into that
uh the key point is that this is a
certificate of singularity
because if if the space were not
singular then there would exist a matrix
a
of rank a full rank
and the image of a times u where u
ranges over the subspace itself would
have dimension uh exactly equal to u
right
so uh
so this page cannot be singular
right so so such a subspace is a witness
or a certificate of singularity and it
is quite function right so ignoring bit
complexities you could just give a basis
uh and it would have at most n vectors
in it and
that would certify and computing this
and verifying this is algorithmically
not very hard
the hard part is to come up with such a
u
so for example if your a is the space of
matrices or whose first column is zero
and uh
u is a subspace where the second
column is zero and the first is
arbitrary then this is a shrunk subspace
because the image is the zero vector
right
so this is a very simple example
uh
so this is one kind of certificate the
other is what we call a linear kernel
so collection or tuple of vectors v1 up
through vm
is a linear kernel
if this polynomial so summation x i
times e i and summation x times mvi is
identically zero
now again
uh
the element on the left for a fixed x is
a certain vector
uh is a certain matrix sorry uh in the
space in the matrix space
and summation x i v i is a certain
vector
and by this relation it's in the kernel
of the send matrix
okay and this being identically zero
means that this holds for every x
so for every matrix in your space
you have an explicit vector in its
kernel and therefore proving that it is
singular
right
and moreover
coming up with such a certificate is in
fact much easier than the strong
subspace because you can brute force
search for such a bi
in polynomial time
it's uh you set up a system of linear
equation in m times n variables and
this being identically zero gives you
a lot of linear constraints
right
so
so these are two special certificates
that we know
so let's start with a bit of history
so let's denote
by this
sphere the entire set of singular matrix
spaces
then we have a family of uh
examples coming from the classical
problem of metroid parity and graph
rigidity
and in our language we can think of that
uh as each ai being ranked and skew
symmetric
and
these have linear kernels
right
and we have algorithms for these white
box algorithms for this by laws in 89
and recently the graphic is the case was
generalized
to certain families of pit by raj and
victoria
now regarding family switch from
subspaces
we have a very special family there
which come
from uh matrices whose ranks are one so
if each of your ai has a rank one then
this uh is a case of the metroid
intersection problem
and classically algorithms were given
by edmunds
in the 70s and lowash proved that they
did have some subspaces
moreover evanyoshkarpinski chow and
santa
gave an algorithm to compute the maximum
rank matrix in the space
even if the input ai does not have rank
one right so even if you give a
different basis uh not necessarily such
a nice basis you can still compute the
maximum rank matrix in polynomial time
deterministic for normal time
and gujar and kirov
came up with a quasi-polynomial time
black box algorithm
so
the other algorithms that i'm going to
talk about are all white box whereas
this was a black box algorithm
and this came from a line of work regard
uh on deranimization of the isolation
level
all right
recently
the more general case of shunt subspaces
or non-commutative rank
was solved using
analytic techniques
by garg goodwill's oliveira and
victorisian
where they use gradient descent like
methods
to
[Music]
give a polynomial time algorithm to
decide whether there are some substances
over fields of characteristic zero
and a very different algebraic algorithm
was given by ivanya's tau and
subramanyam
which works over every field
and moreover uh also outputs the witness
the sun subspace
all right
however
these algorithmic techniques don't
really generalize
very easily
for example the ones
using metroid properties
uh very specifically need
the fact that the ranks
the matrices are of this very special
form
whereas these techniques are much more
general
however
a recent result of markham and wickerson
showed that
you cannot really extend them
very easily to the entire space of
singular matrices
because when you have some subspace
you can interpret that algebraically as
a null code membership problem
and they showed that the space of all
singular matrices is not a null cone
for any reasonable group action
right
so this brings us
to a very natural question
of
solving stit
for a larger family right so we have
shrunks of spaces on one hand
we have linear kernels
on the other hand so these are faces
which have linear kernels these are
spaces which have some subspaces
and then
there are certain isolated examples
there is a family of two symmetric
matrices of what type
and the question that we ask is what
else do we have
right because if we wish to solve sdit
for the entire class of singular spaces
we need to find
newer families
and solve sdit for them
right
so
that was a very quick uh
summary of the results
uh however avi has a very nice talk at
is
on these questions it's a much longer
talk and it outlines the connections and
the history in a lot of detail so do
check that out
so now we have our goal which is to find
more examples
of matrix spaces
and it's always city for them
right
and with this we come
to our results
and
our results are
as for those so in the first one
we construct a new
family of examples
so
we show that certain
uh
class of matrix spaces coming from
what we call what are called matrices
uh indeed
possess neither strong subspaces
nor uh have linear kernels
so this family in particular uh
encompasses this example of skew
symmetric matrices
a word size
but it's a much larger family
and in the second
key result we give a deterministic
polynomial time algorithm
to test whether space is able
right
so on one hand we show that these are
new examples and they don't possess the
kind of certificates we've already seen
and
before the given algorithm
to compute
whether it is singular or not
right
so that's the result in an action
and
and make this more precise but to do so
we need a few definitions
uh
starting with what the li algebra is
so let's start off with a special case
called the matrix 3 algebra
a subspace of
n by n matrices
is
a matrixly algebra
if it is closed under the commutator
right so the commutator is this
operation which you might have seen
so for two matrices a b you have a b
minus b a
and if your space is closed under such
an operation it's a matrices algebra
so
for example
the space of all n by matrices is
clearly closed so that forms a matrix
the algebra
but
you have more non-trivial families like
sln or a field which is the space of all
traceless matrices
or the space of skew symmetric matrix
right these are all
matrix key algebras
and
we further need the definition
of an irreducible matrixy algebra
which is another process that for any
non-trivial subspace so any subspace
that is not the all zero or
the all
or the entire space
a times u is not contained in u
right
so recall the definition of a times u
which is the image of a and u for every
matrix in the space and every vector in
the subspace
right
so now we state the result
more formally
uh which is that every non-zero
irreducible magnificent algebra over the
complex numbers
has no chunks of space
right
and the key idea here to prove this
is to show that if you have a strong
subspace
then you can construct uh an invariant
subspace u which is non-trivial
which would contradict the definition of
it being irreducible
right
and to do that
and also let me mention that
this result was also independently
obtained by markham anderson uh
and the proof technique is quite
different and they use representation
whereas as we'll see we'll use the
correspondence with lead groups
so let's look at this correspondence
between the groups and the algebras
so this beautiful image uh
is by timothy but adapted uh
by an image by kenyan
so what is the level a lead group is a
group
that has an additional structure of
being a manifold
and you have this group operations
actually being
topologically continuous maps
and the correspondence is that for lee
algebras over the complex numbers
can be seen as tangent spaces
at the identity
of lead groups right so for every
algebra there is a sleep group whose
tangent space gives you this algebra
so for example
the algebra slm
of traceless matrices
can be seen as the tangent space
as the lee algebra
of the lead group sln
on n by n matrices with determinant 1.
so the name is not a coincidence
and we'll use this uh notation to denote
the liaison process
so lee of g denominator
right
so now
the proof sketch is briefly as follows
so we would like to show that the chunks
of spaces give rise to invariant
subspaces that is subspaces is that a of
q is containing
right so instead of proving that its
invariant under the algebra we would
like to prove that it is invariant under
the lead group
and then we show a lemma stating uh that
that's a cycle that if a subspace is
invariant under the lead group it is uh
invariant under the earlier
and the other
key idea
is that of a canonical strum subspace
right
so if your matrix space has chunks of
spaces
or in other words if it is
non-commutative singular
then there is a special subspace called
canonical shunt subspace
which is invariant under stabilizers
so a stabilizer is a matrix
which under conjugation so
so if you take the matrix p and you
conjugate it by x you recover the matrix
space right
so such matrices that
are called stabilizers
and we show that
there is a special subspace
which is invariant under stabilizers
right
and then
we use the fact
that any lead group stabilizes its lead
so therefore
since it stabilizes silly algebra by
this lemma
it is invariant
so this canonical structure space is
invariant under the lead group
and by the first lemma we have that it
is invalid under the algebra which is
right so that is more or less the entire
proof here
and as you can see it is
quite a short proof
save for this level
right and this can be generalized beyond
the irreducible case so i stated it
initially right now for an irreducible
algebra
but
let a be any matrix the algebra then you
can
have a composition series
which is a set of irreducible matrices
algebra
and each of them is called a composition
factor
by a theorem by a well-known classical
theorem
this set is
not unique but it's unique up twice
model
so these factors are unique up to
isomorphism
and
the theorem says that for any such
for any matrices algebra
you look at all the composition factors
if none of them are 0
then you do not have some substance
on the other hand if any of these are
zero then definitely you will have some
substance
right so this gives a complete
characterization
so having looked at
some subspaces
let's look at linear kernel
and the statement is as follows let g be
a semi-simple algebra over complex
numbers and row be any irreducible
representation
then the matrix space which is the image
of g under row has a linear kernel
if and only if
rho is either the zero map
or it is isomorphically a joint
representation
right so a note for the expert is that
here we can assume without loss of
generality that role is faithful and the
theorem holds over every algebraically
close field of characteristic
distance from towards
uh
but
a lot of these terms
need definitions and let us now define
this term
and then we'll come back to the result
so
so let's take a step back and
ask ourselves how can we build matrix
liaison right how do you come up with
such spaces which are closed under this
communicator bracket
so to do that we define an abstract
liaison so for any vector space
g
uh to turn it into a lea algebra you
need a lee bracket that is a bilinear
map
which has the following two properties
the first is that it is anti-symmetric
so the bracket of x y is negative
written by x and
this implies in particular that x comma
x is zero
and moreover it satisfies a certain
identity called the jacobi identity
which is a
a different form of associativity in a
way
but i'll not state it here because we
don't need it
so once you have a bracket with these
two conditions
then
you have an abstractly algebra
for example the matrixy algebra is alia
algebra because the commutator satisfies
these properties
and
given any such abstractly algebra we can
construct a matrixy algebra outfit by
mapping in to the space of matrices so
here glb
are
all matrices
which are basically thought of as
maps from v to itself
right so there are dimension v times
dimension b
uh size matrices
and we denote it in this way to
uh
make
to make it clear that it is a matrix
diagram that it has this communicator
and
the key condition we need from such a
map is compatibility with bracket so row
of x y
is uh the commutator of provision rho by
so on the right is the commutator of
matrices whereas on the left the bracket
is the abstract one
with which the liaison battery is
equipped
so once you have such a map row
that satisfies the compatibility
condition you can look at the image
of the liaison brand at the back and
that gives the matrix y algebra
precisely because it is the
compatibility condition ensures that it
is closed under the communicator
and this space the pair row comma v
is called a representation of the
algebra
right so for example if you already had
a basically algebra then you can just
take the map to the identity and it
satisfies the
security
so now every lia algebra has a
particular special representation
associated with it called the adjoint
representation
so here you take the vector space v to
be
g itself
and the map
adjoint which i denote here by add
acts as follows so add x
is a linear map from g to itself
which takes y and maps it to x from y
right
so since the bracket is a bilinear map
once i fix x it gives me a linear map
and this linear map goes from g to g
therefore it lies
in gld or the space of all
maps from e2
right all right
and this uh
representation is very special for
multiple reasons
and uh we can define simplicity using
this so aliyah zebra is simple
uh
if
space is irreducible
as a matrixly algebra
and it is very simple if uh it is uh if
it can written as a direct sum of simple
yields
right so this is what it means for a
li algebra to be semi simple
and now let us see that adjoint
representations give rise to spaces with
linear kernels
right so let's say that matrix space was
indeed the image of this
so let's fix the basis and assume that
add of a1 so on up to add of n
forms the basis of the space
a
right
then i claim that the vectors a1 through
a form a linear curve for this
and to verify we just plug it in the
definition
so
so this
is
an element in the matrix space summation
x i times at a i
and here the linear kernel is formed by
x i times a
once you multiply it out you get two
terms
uh terms of the form x i squared in
terms of the form x i x j
the coefficient here is add a i
applied on a i which by this definition
is the bracket of ai on itself
and from the anti-symmetric property we
know that it is zero
similarly for the terms xixa you have
ai
bracket aj and bracket of aj ai
and again
by the anti-symmetry this
right
so
we very
easily seen that adjoint representation
gives rise to spaces with linear current
right
but now the question is
what is the criteria for other
representations to have such a
kernel
right because there are a lot of other
representations their joint is just one
of them
and
the theorem says
that essentially
that is the only one
right so either it's a zero map
in which catcher trivially has been
occurred is
or because the adjoint it's isomorphic
could be a joint representation
okay so so this is the key theorem
and
we in fact give uh two proofs of this
here
so the first uses density arguments
and the key result there that is used is
the fact that every semi-simple the
algebra
can be generated by 12
and this is true over
close fields
of characteristics which are not two and
three
the other proof goes by the route of
chevalier basis and here the key fact is
that every semi-simple algebra has a
certain root structure
and has a very special basis called the
cheval level
and using this
you can also give a proof
all right so now that you've
seen
that
the matrix spaces does not possess these
two kinds of certificates
we give a polytime algorithm
which tests the singularity of such a
matrixy algebra
and the key
reduction here is to a very simpler case
which is
the space of upper triangular middle
or rather upper triangularizability
so sdit for
upper triangular spaces is easy
because if you have a matrix that is
upper triangular then it's determinant
is this the product of the diagonal
terms
and since each term is a linear form
you have
essentially a problem which is pip for a
product of linear forms
so in the in the notation of circuits
this like a depth to circuit
a pi sigma circuit which is quite easy
for
okay
now the key difficulty is to uh
come up with uh such a reduction
and this uh
is via classical notion of a car concept
algebra
so every matrix
algebra a
for every matrix lee algebra a you have
the special sub algebra h
which has the following two nice
properties
the first is that h is singular
if and only if a so thinking of h as the
negative space
uh its singularity is the same as that
of a
and that lets us uh
reduce the problem to it so sdit for s
is
and crucially
it is upper triangularization which
means that there is a basis change so
you can you have a matrix t such that
upon conjugation
you get an upper ranking space
uh note that you don't really have to
compute such a thing you just having
knowing that it is
of this form implies that the
determinant of this
is a product of linear forms
all right
and computing this carbon sub algebra uh
is achieved by an older algorithm uh due
to the graph given here rhonda
who gave a polynomial time deterministic
atom to compute a carbon sub algebra for
any matrix reaction
so combining it with this fact
uh
we obtain a simple uh
algorithm that solves sdit for this
class of
spaces
all right so let's conclude
so we have seen
that representations of the algebra
which are nothing but matrices algebras
give examples of singular spaces which
do not have shunt substances
or in other words they are fully
non-computative than
moreover
they also do not have a much simpler
certificate uh which is linear
coordinates
and this rules out uh
brute force linear algebraic algorithms
like trying to just uh search for the
certificate
and on the other hand
we do have a polynomial time
deterministic algorithm to decide
singularity of such spaces
by this reduction into car transfer
and
there are a bunch of open problems here
uh
first there are technical uh issues like
uh the field
so
the result on some subspaces
only works over the complex numbers
because of our usage of correspondence
with lead groups
so it would be nice to have a proof that
extends to other fields
moreover every algorithm here is bypass
because we assume that we have the ai
the matrices ai as input
right but in the black box setting you
could only compute the determinant
uh in oracle way and not really have
access to these ai's
so can we make black box
and
of course there are still a large family
for examples waiting to be discovered
and uh
potentially a very large and we have
singularity witnesses
so thank you so much for listening to
the talk
i'll be very happy to hear feedback from
you and answer your questions so please
write to me
at my email
thank you see you at the conference